[Music]
thank you
after months of speculation Donald Trump
confirmed that he does plan to seek the
Republican nomination for 2024.
however what are his chances and has he
rushed the announcement to discuss I'm
now driven by Freddie gray and Jacob
halbron
so Freddie Donald Trump is back he is
trying to make Trump 2024 happen are you
surprised not really no I think there
was a little bit of Doubt uh was cast
about I spoke to some people who who
speak to Trump as people love to say uh
on a regular basis and uh the last week
and I was I was struck that they sounded
a little bit more dubious a bit more
doubtful I think there was a little bit
of uh disappointment disgruntlement with
the midterms and it's feeling that maybe
project Trump isn't going so well but if
you look at it sort of if you pan out a
bit and look at it more broadly Trump
has never really stopped campaigning uh
for the last 10 years really uh he has
always done these rallies when he was in
the white house he did the rallies it
was pretty much as soon as he was out of
the White House he was still doing the
rallies the fundraising has always
carried on it's a business the Trump
campaign is a business
um and the incentives for it to carry on
are very strong so I think it's no real
great surprise
um that you announced Jacob you think
that the timing of this is related to
the midterms because lots of people were
questioning uh Trump's electoral appeal
you can look at some of those results
from the candidates who is so closely
Affiliated to Donald Trump as it meant
he's rushed forward this announcement to
keep momentum going he has indeed the
timing was unpropicious just as his
speech fell flat at Mar-A-Lago the
difficulty he faced was he had
anticipated as many Americans had that
there would be a red wave which turned
into barely even a ripple the idea was
originally that he would emerge as the
triumphant Victor from the midterms that
the candidates that he had endorsed
particularly for the Senate would win
instead
almost all of them crashed and burned
including in Pennsylvania where Mehmet
Oz the doctor that he endorsed lost to
John fetterman this these defeats were
ignominious for Trump and have triggered
in incipient Civil War in the GOP over
him he felt he had no choice but to try
and position himself in front of it by
declaring his candidate he seen now the
difficulty for him I think is that in
declaring prematurely
the the sizzle is gone he's going to be
campaigning now for two years Ron
DeSantis in Florida will wait and let
Trump
essentially burn out over the next
couple months
is chances um Freddy is he now
ultimately seen as the most likely pick
or do you think that Donald Trump still
has a decent shot of this I think the
bookmakers are now making him the
favorite I think that might be a little
premature Jacob makes a very good point
that Trump is now going to be
campaigning for too long and people do
seem to be a bit exhausted with him even
some of his old fans are getting tired
of him
um but DeSantis uh is not quite the
perfect candidate that um everybody
thinks he is nobody is the perfect
candidate and he is very much an old
establishment Republican at heart
and Trump will attack him as a rhino
that means a republican in name only and
those attacks might be unfair but they
will certainly stick and I think people
will see that that DeSantis embraced
Trump trumpism that is very famous
embarrassing campaign advert he did
where he sort of showed himself reading
Trump's book The Art of the deal to his
baby he was just sucking up to Trump in
a big way and people see that DeSantis
embraced trumpism because it was of the
smart clever thing to do
they might think
uh he's not really a True Believer
um that said the status has been a very
clever operator as governor and we
shouldn't underestimate him can I
interject yeah I have to correct Freddie
on this okay my okay he's correct right
let's stand ready to be corrected the to
call DeSantis a rhino I don't think is
fair I didn't say he was I said Trump
will call him I think it will be very
difficult for Trump to do that there's
one big reason he is going to campaign
to the right of Donald Trump on the
covid issue he's going to say that
Donald Trump was responsible for the
lockdowns that Donald Trump stood by
Anthony fauci he will Pummel him on that
and he will say that in Florida by
contrast we did not order lockdowns we
kept the schools open and we did not
kowtow to the federal government headed
by both Donald Trump and then Joe Biden
so I think DeSantis will put Trump in a
difficult position I'm not saying that
he necessarily wins the nomination he
does have some weaknesses that I think
will be very hard for Trump to pick to
Tar him as some kind of a closet liberal
Republican I take that point and I think
Trump is weak to his right uncovered
stuff uh notably the vaccines vaccine
mandates Candace Owens who was a sort of
trump sycophant for a long time has come
out recently and and sort of declared
that she felt he was he treated her
unfairly because he she dared questioned
him about the vaccine mandates uh and so
I do think Trump is weak to his right
and there's a little bit of
disenchantment uh on the right however
he is the Godfather he is trumpism with
it without Trump you don't have trumpism
so a lot of these essays being written
at the moment about the future of the
writers trumpism without Trump that's
nonsense to a certain extent because
it's a non-sequitur uh he is the father
of the movement
Gene what about Donald Trump's legal
issues and what impact is this going to
have on his campaign well his obvious
attempt is to defuse the legal issues by
depicting himself as a victim of a rogue
justice department that is out to
demolish the Republican front-runner for
the presidential nomination I don't
think that that tactic will work and I
think he is going to be facing legal
liability it will however intensify his
bond with the Republican base I think it
will cause him more difficulties with
mainstream Republicans because it won't
just it's likely to be more than one
indictment but we'll see the justice
department has not moved ahead yet and
would need to have an iron-clad case on
the on the documents that he speared it
away to Mar-A-Lago and Merrick Ireland
the attorney general has been
exceedingly cautious in making any
public statements about Trump so right
now we're in a state of suspended
animation there is this interesting
Dynamic though isn't there Jacob
um the Department of Justice and the
Democrats behind it they do want to
persecute Trump uh for the reason that
they want Trump to run so they it helps
them if they can create this conspiracy
theory
um if they can make the conspiracy
theory true that they are out to
persecute Trump because they think their
best ticket for winning is for Trump to
still be around well I personally do not
think that the justice department is out
to persecute Trump in fact if you listen
to the Democratic base they're howling
that Merrick Garland is a sniveling
coward who doesn't have the cojones to
go after Trump I think it's it's all
overdone
um I I Biden has has kept himself out of
this this were the Trump Administration
yes I'm sure Trump would be paying for
his adversaries heads in fact we know
that Trump tries to sick the IRS on his
opponents according to his former Chief
of Staff John Kelly so I think I think
you think the Mar-A-Lago raid is is
purely in the interests of justice and
preserving that I mean they presidential
the question isn't why they went into
mar-a-laga but why they waited so long
they gave the guy every opportunity in
the world to cough these up the man is
pathological whether he did it for
reasons of ego or because he wanted to
sell the documents I don't know but the
whole thing is utterly bizarre and
consonant with Trump's presidency which
was let's face it a debacle and just
finally and when you're looking at those
midterms ultimately the Democrats had a
better than expected performance so what
does that mean for Joe Biden are the
Democrats has stuck with him when it
comes to the next election well Joe
Budden reportedly has a spring in his
step this week and is in excellent
Spirits because he feels that he's been
Vindicated somewhat by these results uh
I think the Democrats should probably uh
not be quite so dreamy about what's
going to happen it looks like America is
about to enter a double dip recession
the broader outlook for the next two
years does not look good
and Joe Biden's performance is generally
seen as bad as job approval ratings are
low the right track wrong track
um meter or an American vast majority of
Americans think their country is on the
wrong track I think they could feel some
pain in 2024 particularly if they think
that project Biden is working more than
it actually is I couldn't disagree more
okay excellent let's go I know you're
shock but I've been a uh a Biden uh
bullish on Biden since the beginning I
think he is he is not a burden on the
party but he is the only one only
Democrat that can defeat Trump again he
will run again and he will win in 2024.
can he defeat DeSantis that would be a
rougher road but the Republican program
is the midterm show is not that popular
so I think Biden would have a strong
chance yes
thank you Jacob thank you Freddie
[Music]